Thank you.
you you got 10 minutes to do it thanks very much Thank you.
So the time being 930 and we have scheduled CACR 13 dealing with legislator compensation.
I have a pin card for two people.
So I would call on the prime sponsor, Representative Deshaies.
I think you need to push that.
There you go.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
I think you need to push that.
There you go.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, the red means go.
That's a little backwards.
We should fix that.
Well, thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Committee, for letting me speak to CIA.
Were you going to say something, Mr.
Chair?
Okay.
To To a constitutional CACR13 relating to legislator compensation.
This legislation seeks to reduce legislators pay including the speaker and the Senate president to two cents for our biennium session.
It also reduces our daily pay for special session to one cent.
I'm going to be fairly brief.
There's not too much to this legislation.
The purpose is to just meet the current expectations Granite Staters have for legislative compensation in New Hampshire.
Granite Staters are told we're volunteers and we make no salary, and this constitutional amendment, if approved by the voters, will ensure we are true volunteers.
So why should we move our pay to two cents?
Well, the reason is to ensure, well, why should we keep our pay?
Well, the reason why I decide to keep our pay instead of completely eliminating it like 10 to 15 other states have is to ensure there's no complications for legislators who participate in the state's health care plan.
I know municipalities in New Hampshire compensate volunteer firefighters or other volunteer positions who undo things for the municipality at $1 a year for the same reasons to ensure that they're still considered employees.
I'm not sure how it works constitutionally for our state legislators, but I didn't want to run into that issue as that being a barrier to pass this.
I would encourage the committee to amend CACR 13 to make legislators pay $0 if it means the zero dollar pay doesn't complicate legislators acquiring the benefits that they paid into for the system that they paid into.
If voters approve this constitutional amendment, it will save the state $85,000 a year.
I know this is minuscule to the entirety of the state budget, but currently the $85,000 isn't being utilized in the most efficient or effective way possible.
The $200 to $200 we're paid every biennium has really no demonstrable ways helps legislators better serve their constituents.
The state could better allocate our tax dollars on almost nearly anything else in our budget.
I'd suggest hiring more staff at the Office of Legislative Services myself, but that would be a decision for the Finance Committee to make for our next state budget.
I think we should give the voters a voice and allow them to choose if New Hampshire's lawmakers will become, you know, truly volunteer legislators and if law or if they're gonna let us still collect our $200 in taxpayer money for our own personal use.
I think this is just enabling voters to have that voice to say, you know, New Hampshire politicians should be volunteers.
They shouldn't be getting the $200.
The $200 doesn't serve any utility to overall how we do our services for them or most of our daily lives.
So I think that we should let the voters have the choice to make that decision to lower our pay and make it next to zero.
And if possible, the committee could amend it and make it so then we're full volunteers that don't make any compensation.
That's all.
Thank you.
Will you accept questions from the committee if there are any?
Yep.
Are there any I can but it's mostly just bullet notes but if you wouldn't if you'd like me to yeah I get I can email it to you if you'd like is it easier for the clerk okay I'll submit it then I'll email it to you if you'd like.
It's purely up to you, whatever you want to do.
Is it easier for the clerk?
It's just something to submit, yes.
Okay, I'll submit it, then I'll send it to you in an email when I get home.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Any others?
No?
We're good?
One real quick.
It seems obvious, but I just want to make sure.
So in the CACR, the basically zero compensation would remain a part of the Constitution.
We're not pulling pay out of the Constitution.
The Constitution would simply say that at this point we make one cent or two cents or whatever the compensation is.
Correct.
We're just, it's just amending our current because our compensation is based on, it says shall on, I believe it's line three of the bill.
So line three.
Yep.
On line three it says shall.
I believe it's line three of the bill so line three yep on line three it says shall and so basically we constitutionally bind you know our our government to pay us that amount and instead of getting rid of compensation because I believe there should be some kind of you know in our Constitution it should be constitutional what our pay is we're just asking the voters to approve a constitutional amendment to make it two cents.
It's not going to affect any other kinds of things like mileage.
It's just the biennium compensation that legislators are given to kind of give some historical context.
$200 back when the voters last approved the legislative pay increase was equivalent, adjusted for inflation, a little over $5,000.
We haven't adjusted it since.
A reason for that is because expectations have changed, right?
Times have changed, right?
People used to come down here on horses or would walk to legislative sessions, right, from Coas County, Carroll County, Grafton County, right?
So that would actually take possibly weeks, right, that they'd have to give up of farms that they tended to or local businesses now we drive you know getting to session for example is me waking up taking a warm shower you know using plumbing coming down here in a car in an hour and giving my testimony and I'll drive home and get back to work which I'll do online from home right so times have changed we can do this fully volunteer and I think the voters kind of have that expectation at this point so we should have our Constitution reflect that but with their approval okay yep so I think you know some of the things that we Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Speedy.
So I think, you know, some of the things that we, like, you know, I know that the 200 isn't, you know, I don't use this to live my lavish lifestyle, but there are a few, you know, things that we do pay for.
They're not a lot.
I mean, license plates, business cards, probably nameplates.
So would you be open to the idea of maybe reducing it to $20 to cover that?
Because I know that these are just small fees, but they're some of the things we do pay for.
I hear you, Representative Speedy, and thank you for your question.
I don't think so.
I think many of those things are luxuries.
I think they're not necessary to do our job necessarily and I think people when they run should understand the kind of responsibilities that they assume and if they think that they need a license plate or business cards to do the job then that's something that they should consider.
You know I knew when I ran for office I knew there'd be certain costs and certain amount of time that I'd have to give up in my day to be able to do this.
And it's something I love to do for my constituents.
And I assume everyone in the room feels the same way.
But I think we tell voters we're volunteers.
I think the $85,000 we spend on volunteers could be better spent elsewhere in our budget.
And I think letting the voters choose to approve an amendment that would properly reflect the pay that they expect I think is a um I think it's the right thing to do personally but that's going to be the committee's ultimate decision no no follow-up representative thank you thank you for taking my question I'm sorry I came in a little late um and so I didn't hear all of your testimony.
I'm assuming that you are aware that representatives need to take the $200 or the $100 a year, and in fact there is a way that you just contact the offices and tell them that you do not want to accept the salary, such as I do.
Are you aware of that?
I am aware, but I don't think there should be any option to even accept.
Follow up?
Follow up.
So the folks that really do rely on this to offset some of their expenses, they understand that they're not getting a salary like the folks out in the community.
Have you done any kind of research as to the folks that are currently accepting the salary and whether or not they know that they do not have to accept that salary and give them the process for it?
Thank you for your question, Representative.
I have not done any research into that, but I certainly can if you'd like me to.
No, I'm not asking you to.
Thank you for your question representative I have not done any research into that but I certainly can if you'd like me to.
No I'm not asking you to.
Thank you.
Okay.
Done.
I have one question.
Is it your belief that the current $200 for two years is not considered volunteerism by the general public?
That's a tough question.
Well, thank you for your question first, Mr.
Chairman, and that's a tough question.
I think it would depend on who you ask.
It would definitely be more of an anecdotal thing.
It's not something that I've ever, you know, genuinely gone around to my constituent and asked them $100, you know, a year compensation volunteering.
But I'm not sure entirely if $200 is, I think it's, first off, the kind of cost that we've discussed that, you know, some legislators might say that they need, which I still think is optional, but like a license plate, business cards, et cetera, isn't much more than $40 or $50.
So if that's the kind of cost we're talking about covering, right, then we're definitely overcompensating our legislators by about four times as much.
I still think that legislators before they assume the office or even decide to run for the office should know the assumed cost.
I still think that the voters should have the option of whether or not to essentially zero out our pay, and that's for the committee to decide.
Thank you.
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you for having me.
Appreciate it.
Chair will call Timothy Horrigan for two minutes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much Mr.
Chair.
I'll try to keep it around two minutes but I can't guarantee.
I submitted a...
Maybe I'll take my mask off so I can be heard more clearly.
I submitted what appeared to be a similar CACR, which eliminated the provision, and I think it went to another committee and was ITL unanimously.
And then it was one of the bills that kind of ended up in limbo, just because of the strange way we did things in 2021.
And actually probably this CSR probably under normal circumstances probably couldn't have been brought forward because it's so similar to the other one.
My intent, and I think the intent of the prime sponsor but she can't speak for herself she's elsewhere today was actually we would set our salary in statute like we do for all the other state offices including including actually the county delegation each of us belongs to a county delegation, and there is actually an RSA 24 where we set our salaries for that one, although that's also a fairly token amount, except when I have an executive committee meeting that gets over in 20 minutes, maybe $25 for that is fair compensation.
So I think there's no dishonor in paying people for the work, including ourselves.
And so I certainly, I'm certainly, I was not aware that you can refuse a check.
I do know that some members do donate their salary checks to charity.
I've heard of that.
And also there's a whole thing with the-2s, where some members say they're not employees, and so don't fill out the W-2.
But it gets the history of it.
Representative Deshaies correctly pointed out that when we put this in the Constitution in 1887, we got $100 a year and it's been unchanged ever since.
And then, so that would be probably about $5,000.
That would be about, but actually at the same time, the governor's salary that year, Governor Moody Currier, I only remember that because I was looking at my testimony from last year, he made, I think, $143,000.
No, he made $2,000.
This year, Chris Sununu made a little over $143,000.
If $120,000 would be a little over $7,000.
I think that would probably be a more appropriate figure than $100.
Of course, anybody who doesn't feel like they want to accept a check are free to turn it down, free to donate to charity or whatever.
But I think that's actually probably, if you multiply the amount of time it does to do this job at a minimally competent level times the minimum wage, and of course what the minimum wage is under controversy, that's not out of line.
Adjusted to inflation, it's somewhat less than that.
That would be, I think, about 2,600.
That's also better than 100.
So I basically feel there's no dishonor in paying people.
I think it makes us take it a little bit more seriously, which is not a problem with any of the members on this committee, but there are other members who maybe don't take it as seriously as they should.
And perhaps after they're making something more than a token salary they would make more of an effort I always tell people I'm worth every penny of the hundred dollars a year they pay me so I guess that's what I'm so I think probably the best thing to do this is ITL it's just like you we did year with CACR5.
Hopefully we'll be able to actually get it to the floor and vote ITL instead of that silly miscellaneous.
And failing that at some point, I think we do need to look into perhaps raising the salary to something that's more akin to what $100 a year was in 1887.
And so certainly something in the mid-four figures would not be inappropriate, and that would probably enable a wider cross-section of society to be able to afford to run for it, because it costs a lot more than $40 to run.
And just one more thing, we were hearkening back to how it was in the good old days like in the 17th in the 18th and 19th centuries and long in the 20th century actually what happened was the full contingent would we'd get together in december for organization day they would come back on new year around new year's day for a few days on january 1st and they would usually stay in hotels or boarding houses in time and And we were also paid mileage, which is a lot more.
The mileage was a lot more than it is today.
It wasn't until about 1960 that the mileage payments were fixed at the level they are at now.
And so they would come for a little while in January.
Then they'd go back.
and then not that everybody was a farmer but when those of us who were those members who were in agriculture finished planting their crops and things calmed down a little in June, they would usually get together for like a month or two, and then if necessary come back in the fall.
So they used to have a somewhat different rhythm, so people didn't used to commute back and forth every day.
And actually for a long time, we got free railroad passes, which would be kind of the equivalent in today's terms of giving everyone a free Uber pass, which is, you know, that was like a very, that was probably like a very valuable piece of compensation back then.
So anyway, I think we should be paid something, and, you know, $100 a year is more appropriate than two cents.
So I think I'm perfectly comfortable continuing to pay the legislators.
And there's probably some value, I think it makes us more sympathetic to the concerns of working people too, if we're at least paid salary even if it's not a huge one.
Thanks.
So that's basically the urgent ITL which I would be very surprised if any other result came out of the committee when you vote on it.
But thank you.
Thank you.
Will you take questions if there are any?
Even though I'm well over my two minutes I'm sure.
Nope, we're all set.
Thank you.
Will you take questions if there are any?
Sure.
Even though I'm well over my two minutes, I'm sure.
Yeah.
Nope, we're all set.
Thank you very much.
All right, thank you.
I have no other pink cards.
With that, we have a 10-minute respite until 10 o'clock when we will be hearing CACR 23.
be able to shut that off there we go Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, we're back 10 o'clock by my clock.
the hearing on CACR 23, which deals with reference to persons in the New Hampshire Constitution being gender neutral.
We have the prime sponsor, Representative LaBranch, scheduled for just two minutes, but welcome to legislative administration.
Glad to be here and thank you, Chairman.
I will keep it very brief.
It's a very simple CACR.
It simply seeks to make the Constitution gender neutral as in instead of he or she, which is a similar CACR in 1997, which passed both the House and Senate on bipartisan votes.
It is the same bill except of he or she.
It will say the governor or whatever position is referenced in the Constitution.
The reason that it did not pass fully was when it was put to the voters in 1998, it failed to meet the threshold.
It was just 10% shy from passing, with 56% of New Hampshire voters voting in favor of this CACR.
This is, like I said, a very similar CACR.
Instead of making it three words, he or she, it will just say the title of the position that it is talking about so that is pretty much my testimony it's very simple and I'm happy to answer any questions that the committee might have thank you for your brevity we do have one question for you Representative Roulard.
Hi.
Thanks for taking my question.
How many other states have done this to their constitutions?
It is, to the best of my knowledge, at least 10 other states have made their constitutions just very technical documents that only state the name of the position and not using any gendered terminology like he or she in their constitutions.
Follow up?
Follow up.
Does that mean that they went back and edited their constitution or was their constitution worded differently in the beginning?
In some cases, it was just they wrote it that way.
In other states, I know on the West west coast they've gone back and changed it so that it is gender neutral as I seek to do today with a referendum when the CICR passes the House and Senate do you know how many went back and changed the gender how many states on the top of my head I do not know but I could get that to the committee later today thank you further questions thank you mr.
chairman thank you for taking my question um I mean I understand the general scope of what you're trying to accomplish here but you're not insinuating that the language that's there now isn't gender neutral in effect, correct?
Oh, no.
For a fact, it is gender neutral in the eyes of the law.
This is just a very technical change, just to simplify the Constitution.
Follow up?
So, just for clarity from my perspective, from your perspective, what is the ultimate benefit in doing that then?
A lot of this is mostly to update the Constitution with the language of today and the culture of today.
Back when the Constitution was written, women could not vote, and it was he as the gendered term.
This seeks to just update it to our modern day society and gender equality.
I don't see why it should say he or she.
When we're talking about a position such as the governor or the Supreme Court justice or any other term, this is just, I would say, simplifying the Constitution and making it up to date thank you appreciate it representative this media thank you mr.
chair I hate using these type of questions but I you know reading this I had no idea that the Constitution wasn't gender neutral reading you know Constitution says you know the governor his and you know which you know we, we've had a pretty strong history of women governors in the state.
Would you believe that most people don't know that the constitution actually has, isn't gender neutral and mostly male pronouns?
I would agree with that.
And as the previous representative had asked me, in the eyes of the law, it is gender neutral.
This is just a very technical update so that we are very clear about what we are talking about in the Constitution.
I understand that it was probably just the language of the time that they used he or she, or I should say he in this context.
and this would just make it clear that when they're talking about in the Constitution currently it says he shall.
Instead it would say the governor shall.
So it will be more explicitly clear.
I have one question if you don't mind.
It's on page six and line 11.
I'm looking at their excellency.
Would that be how the governor is referred?
Their excellency?
That would be, I don't believe that will be changing at all, his or her excellency.
I believe the the pronoun at the beginning is mostly optional but their excellency is what is used in other countries as well.
So you're saying that someone would, it says whose title shall be their excellency rather than his.
Yep.
So they would be called their excellency.
To my knowledge, when we had female governors, they were not called his excellency either.
This would just clarify that as well because if it says His Excellency currently it doesn't make sense that if we have a female governor we would be saying His Excellency either.
I understand but you're crossing out his and presumably hers if we had a female governor and you would replace that with their excellency.
That is correct.
Anyone else?
No further questions?
Thank you for your testimony.
The chair will call Representative, Representative Murray, representing Hillsborough 22.
Welcome to legislative administration.
Thank you for having me.
So, yes, my position, yes, for the record, my name is Representative Megan Murray.
I represent the town of Amherst.
My pronouns are she, her.
But when I am, I come in support of the CACR as a co-sponsor to the bill.
But I also think that, like the sponsor mentioned, leaving out an entire pronoun here, she, her, is not referenced at all in the Constitution.
I do also think when we were having the discussion about they there, that is a more universal pronoun to be able to use for any person seeking that office.
So I am fully in support of making that change so that there is gender neutral language.
Happy to take any questions if you should have them.
That's okay.
Are there any questions for Representative Murray?
Seeing none, thank you.
Thank you very much.
I have only one other PIN card, and that is for the Honorable Dan Itza.
Inimitable Dan Itza.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Members of the committee, for the record, I am Dan Itza, and I am residing in Manchester.
I do rise in opposition to this, mostly for practical reasons.
As was stated by the prime sponsor, the Constitution that is currently written is accepted as gender neutral.
The pronoun he is generally understood in these contexts to refer to anyone and it's not kept any females from being elected to any position.
So from a practical perspective, it changes nothing.
However, it's been held that generally speaking an amendment to the Constitution should not involve one more than one article at a time, to clarify the situation.
There has been an issue in past constitutional amendments, constitutional conventions, on the 1960s one, I forget what year in particular, but there were so many amendments coming out of that convention that they staggered them.
They didn't offer them all the first opportunity after the convention, but they put two or three in election cycle for several election cycles because it was overwhelming.
Also, I think in a wise move, in about 2006, we required that all amendments be printed on the ballot.
That means that were this to go to the people, disregarding anything else that may be on the ballot, the ballot would be 12 pages long.
For everybody.
That's a substantial document.
Finally, the last time that this number of amendments were made to the Constitution was in 1792 and actually not as many amendments articles were amended as this proposes.
The change to the Constitution was considered so extensive that they re-enrolled the Constitution.
And I think that would be obligated obligatory upon us as well at this point.
So you're taking a much larger step.
We would no longer be under the Constitution of 1792, but the Constitution of 2022.
I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Except I don't see any.
Thank you very much, Honorable Itza.
Welcome back.
Chair has one last pink card for Representative Toll.
Welcome, Representative Toll, to the Legislative Administration.
Thank you very much.
Honorable members of the Legislative Administration Committee, my name is Amanda Elizabeth Toll, and I represent the city of Keene at large.
I am here today to speak in support of CACR 23, which provides that all references to persons in the New Hampshire Constitution be gender neutral.
CACR 23 is a critical component of the movement towards equality for all genders in New Hampshire.
Making this change in the Constitution would be particularly beneficial for enhancing the equality of women and the LGBTQ plus community.
It is my firm belief that all people should be seen and recognized for who they are.
When our state and national constitution were written, women had an extremely limited role in public life and were excluded from the political process.
From the first sentence of the document, which states that all men are born equally free and independent, it reflects the patriarchal values away from which we have been moving as a society since this country's founding.
To paraphrase the UNESCO 2019 Priority Gender Equality Guidelines, the underlying principle of gender-inclusive language is that in all communications, all genders are equal and should be treated and respected equally.
In language, this equality takes the form of overall gender balance and elimination of terms that stereotype, exclude, or demean.
Using gender fair and inclusive language helps reduce gender stereotyping and promotes positive social change.
Updating language use has historically been a critical component of social progress and the movement towards inclusivity for all groups.
Further, enshrining gender equality in language of the Constitution represents a step towards the prevention of social and legal regression as women and LGBTQ plus persons continue to face repeated attempts to limit their agency, bodily autonomy, and self-expression.
Language signals where groups of people exist on the spectrum of equality.
At this point in history, all genders are included in the political process as both voters and as legislators.
The proposed change is one way of affirming that all are welcome in the political process.
This is a step towards enhancing democracy.
Thank you for your time.
I'm going to defer any questions to the prime sponsor.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
seeing no other pink cards, I am going to close the hearing on CACR 23.
And our next CACR 24 will start in just about 30 minutes at 1045.
Thank you.
So by this clock it's 1045 so we will open the hearing on CACR 24 and call the prime sponsor Representative Sober from Belknap 2.
Welcome.
Thank you very much.
Is this thing on?
Oh, there we go.
Yes.
Now it's on.
Yes, it is.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
Thank you for allowing me to make this presentation.
When I filed CACR24, my original feeling was that it seemed to be sort of anomalous to the structure of our government in the state for the Attorney General, the Chief Law Enforcement Officer of the state, to be appointed by the governor, affirmed in what is essentially a rubber stamp by the executive council.
And we look to them, to the attorney general, he or she, to be the chief law enforcement officer.
And the history in the last 10, 15 years of major financial scandals, for example, the The FRM scandal is one of abject interaction, inaction by the Attorney General's office.
So I thought, okay, let's have it elected just like the General Court elects the Secretary of State.
Let's have the AG elected by the General court the same way.
And of course, in my goofy way of working with OLS, I produced the CACR 24, and some wiser heads prevailed and pointed out to me potential ambiguities.
So I basically cribbed their suggestions, sent it to OLS, asked them to do a committee amendment, a proposed committee amendment, and so you should have a copy.
This is 2022-0058H, which basically tinkers with the language, but it's the same thing.
It basically says that the general court, it moves the attorney general out of its one section of the Constitution into the section with the Secretary of State for electoral purposes.
If it passes, there are some, by the electorate, there are some RSAs that next time we would have to deal with and do some adjusting.
No question about that.
I also passed, and there's copies of the amendment for everybody, I also passed out a copy, since we all know that if anything appears on the internet, it must be true, right?
So I picked up from Ballotopedia and Wikipedia an analysis of the states in the country that elect or appoint its attorney general.
And it turns out that 43 states directly elect their attorney general by the people.
43 states.
Seven, we are one of the seven.
Attorney general is appointed by the governor in only five states, our being one, New Jersey, Alaska, Hawaii, and Wyoming.
In Maine, the Attorney General is chosen by the state legislature, while in Tennessee the choice falls to the state Supreme Court.
So 43 states elect directly.
If this committee and members of the committee felt like a further amendment might be appropriate to make the election of the Attorney General done directly by the electorate, I would support it 110%.
I don't know whether there's any taste for that, but I think that whatever the taste is, whether it's to have the general court elected like the Secretary of State is elected or to give it to the people which we seem to want to embody all of our values in the votes of the individuals and the citizens of our state by all means let's do it but the current system doesn't work well and I think it's time for a change and that's all I have to say and I'm happy to take any questions thank you for your testimony are there any questions for the prime sponsor I see one you need to turn on your microphone yeah you have to push the button on your microphone.
There you go.
Can you tell me why you think the current system doesn't work?
Mainly because of my experience in Belknap II, which was the epicenter of the FRM scandal several years ago, in which many of my constituents lost many millions of dollars, and even with the legislature's attempt at setting up this, that's now in the budget, this recovery fund, it will give them a few pennies on the dollar.
When we look back at the analysis of the three agencies involved in oversight of this regulated industry, the only one that was not asleep at the switch was the securities division.
The banking division was probably the worst, and the second was the attorney general's office.
And I can tell you that I had occasion to harangue one of the staff of the Attorney General's office after the dust had settled.
And I said something to the effect, why didn't you guys get on this thing?
And the answer was, well, we were new in the office and we really didn't know what was going on.
And the dog ate our homework, basically homework basically.
So you know basically right now the Attorney General's principal role is prosecuting homicides.
County attorneys prosecute anything but homicides and misdemeanors I guess go down to the the police prosecutors.
So they fine, they can do that, but let's reassert some separation of powers here.
Separation of powers.
Let's let the legislature, either the legislature, do the election of the attorney general, or let's turn it back to the people, which is where it really belongs.
So that's, it's basically my experience with the AG's office mishandling of the FRM scandal.
And I'm sure there's others.
And by the way, the only reason I'm not wearing a mask, for those of you who are mask oriented, is that I had COVID last year, and I recovered, fortunately, and my doctor says that I have very high antibodies and natural immunity now so thank you can you hit your button to take that off representative of the speedy thank you mr.
chair would you be open to amending this to to like the other 43 states to making it elected by the general voting population?
Absolutely.
Not only be open to it, I would strongly support it.
Further questions?
I have one.
So is it your contention that the FRM situation you described wouldn't have occurred had the Attorney General been hired or elected by the general court?
It's my contention that scandals happen, Ponzi schemes and frauds happen all the time.
And whether, however, the attorney general, in a regulated industry, if the attorney general has responsibility for some aspect of policing a regulated industry.
I don't think they could have prevented it, but they could have severely narrowed the scope because they could have caught it early on because there were apparently, reportedly, at least 70 instances of misdeeds and questionable conduct that were reported to the different agencies and no action was taken.
So they wouldn't have eliminated it, but they would have taken it from a wholesale level, which is what it was, down to a very small retail level if they had acted quickly.
My follow-up is, so purely because they were, the Attorney General's office was appointed by the Executive Branch and Counsel, they were less responsive to this?
and your belief is if they were elected by the general court, they would be more responsive to, or maybe that's a bad word to use, but I'm trying to find what part of this process that's being changed is going to solve the issues that you described.
If the Attorney General is elected by the general court or by the people and they have to stand for re-election periodically and they have to stand for re-election on their record, that, I believe, would be a very salutary effect because early on when these events occurred, whether it's FRM or others, and I'm sure there's probably others, that's just the most widely known one, at least they would know that they have to be responsible to someone other than the governor and council.
They have to be responsible to the people, if the people directly elect, as they do in 43 states, or to the general court, just like we elect the Secretary of State.
And would the person holding the office change from term to term if it was elected by the general court?
I mean, look how long Bill Gardner was in office as Secretary of State, running again and again and again.
And there was no problem because he ran a tight ship.
If you run a tight ship, you don't have any problems.
But what I'm trying to do is to put, pardon the expression, the fear of God into people who occupy this position of trust so that we, the people, can actually trust them to do their jobs.
Thank you.
One final question from me.
This would also still remain a two-year term, correct?
Yes.
Yes, correct.
I'm fine.
Anyone else?
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you for the committee members hearing me.
Chair will call the only other pink card that we have honorable Dan it's Thank you, mr.
Chairman members of the committee for the record.
I'm still Dan it's and I still reside in Manchester I Rise in strong support of this amendment, and I think you need to understand how we got to where we are.
This is not a drastic change from the way the state was originally organized.
When from 1784 to 1792 there was legislative involvement in the election of all appointed officers because they were affirmed by the executive council.
The executive council for those eight years was comprised of two senators and three representatives elected by the general court.
So you had legislative oversight of all these appointments and I would really advocate that for the Attorney General, all department heads, and even the judiciary, that there ought to be legislative oversight reinserted.
Because right now, the legislature has no direct input on the executive or judicial branches other than the Secretary of State and the Treasurer.
How would it have changed FRM?
Because for all the years that we tried to get the Attorney General to react to FRM and to voter fraud and things like that, if it were the General Court who in some way, shape or form were doing the approval of the nomination when the legislature made a law that said do this, they would obey.
And that's the important part of this is reinforcing our authority over the executive branch and and it's important to remember that there is nothing in our constitution that says the three branches are equal and in fact the way the document is constructed it is the legislature that is the origin of all power in the state we make the laws the first job of the executive is to follow them and the job of the judiciary is to adjudicate them.
I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
I see one question.
Representative Roulard.
Thank you for taking my question.
Do you think the Attorney General, if you had your preference, should be elected by popular vote of the people or by the legislature?
I think it should be by the legislature.
The legislature reflects the popular will of the people by whom they've elected, and it is a group of people who are more intimately familiar with what is demanded of the Attorney General and the organs of government in general.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
I have one question.
Yes, sir.
Do you see any downside to this type of approach with the Attorney General being elected from the general court?
As has been constructed, the one downside I see is a competitive election, so to speak, people running for office.
If I had written it, I would have made it a nomination by governor and counsel to be affirmed by the legislature in joint session.
Thank you.
One final question.
Were you speaking more to the CACR as it exists the amendment, if you have not seen it?
I don't know.
I have not seen the amendment as it's been described to me.
I don't think it is that different.
I think if I understand correctly, one of the primary issues of the amendment is that it moves the election of the Attorney General into the same session as the Secretary of State, which is executed in the same manner.
It does, thank you.
No further questions, thanks very much for coming in.
No more pink cards.
Here we are again.
That means we have a Thank you.
That means we have a half-hour break, folks.
11.30, we will take up CACR 25.
Thank you.
So the time being 1130, I will open the hearing on CACR 25 and recognize the prime sponsor, Representative LaBrench.
Welcome again.
I always forget to take off my mask.
That's fine.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, members of the Legislative Administration Committee.
You'll be seeing me a lot today.
A lot of my bills are scheduled for today.
This CACR is a simple one.
It's one sentence.
It says, No person shall serve more than 15 terms in either the Senate or the House of Representatives, respectively, of the state.
The reason that I'm bringing this forward, I'm going to give a lot of context here.
Before I entered the legislature, I was very opposed to term limits.
I believe that it is up to the people to elect their representatives, choose who they want to represent them.
You can be amazing and serve 13 terms, but when I got elected and seeing how many people have been serving more than 15 terms, I know one representative has served since the year of my mother's birth, which is a long time, since 1974.
And I believe that the people of New Hampshire deserve a refreshed voice in the legislature And this is what this seeks to do is to prevent a lifetime Membership of the house and Senate of this state I Will take any questions the committee might have.
Thank you.
I see one question.
Representative.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for your testimony.
I personally believe there's a lot of value to experience.
Why would you limit it to 15?
I mean someone could have 16 or a little bit more and have more experience to offer, more insight on some of the issues.
People don't necessarily go stagnant because they're here a long time.
I don't understand what's wrong with going on.
Yeah, I'm asking what's wrong with going more than 15 terms.
When we do the math out, 15 terms, two-year terms, that would be about 30 years of experience in the House and Senate.
I don't believe there's necessarily anything wrong with having experience.
I just believe that there should be a refreshed voice in the legislature with more young representatives and more diversity of opinion in the House and Senate.
Follow up, Mr.
Chairman?
Follow up.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you very much for your comments.
In many parts of the state, it's very difficult to find people to run for the legislature.
And that being the case, if someone lives in a particular area where it's hard to find someone to run, why would you object to someone coming in more than 15 terms if that person's doing a good job?
To that, I would say that it is a structural issue of the New Hampshire House and of the New Hampshire Senate to find candidates for this office.
I believe a lot of that is related to the salary of the office.
There's many people who cannot work full-time and find the time to be a representative.
And this is just a small piece in the puzzle of trying to build a more representative system here in New Hampshire.
Thank you for your answer.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
You're welcome.
Further questions?
Representative Simon.
Are you aware of anybody?
Thank you for taking my question, by the way.
Are you aware of anybody who has been here for, say, 10, 15 terms or so that agrees with your position has the same kind of view as you do on this?
I would say that I believe that most of them are inclined not to support the bill as they are currently further than 15 terms into their terms.
Okay, thank you.
Yes, Representative Green.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Can you tell us how many people in the current legislature this would apply to even?
I mean, it can't be too many, can it?
I would say if I'm doing this off the top of my head, it would be at least 25 representatives With the average age of the New Hampshire House being 65 and myself bringing down that average by two years Being the youngest representative of this body Thank you Any further questions?
I have one.
Thank you for your testimony So my question is do you think this would be taking the privilege from the voters to decide who they want in that office?
I believe in the process of a CACR being passed, it will have to be passed by the voters, and I believe it will be ultimately up to the voters if they want term limits.
This red legislation actually originally comes from a Republican member of my district, but I believe that the diversity of the New Hampshire House is a bipartisan issue, and getting more representatives and diversity of opinion because new voices bring new ideas in the legislature.
Thank you, but I'm not sure you answered my question.
Do you think that the voters in a district that have someone they feel is reflective of their views and this arbitrary number of 15 limits their ability to decide who they want for their representation.
That was originally my concern as well before I entered the legislature.
I see other states like Florida which have term limits and members can only serve two terms and that's not enough to get experience I learned about that in my local government course with Senator Carson but I would say it's up to the voters in the end if they want term limits or not but I do see that as an issue if they would want that individual to run for something else maybe because it says 15 terms in that House of Representatives if they would want to run for Senate they can run for Senate as well.
Okay thank you.
Seeing none thank you very much.
I only have one other pink card for this, and it's the Honorable Dan Itza.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
You're welcome.
Welcome back.
You have to push a button.
There you go.
There we go.
I didn't have to before.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, honorable members of the committee.
I am Dan Itza.
I reside in Manchester.
And I oppose this proposal with everything I can muster.
I spent nine terms in the legislature, so if this passed, I guess I'd only have another potential a another potential of six so you know I could only serve another 12 years.
I view any term limits whether at the state level or the federal level a deprivation of representation.
Selden does anybody want to limit their own legislator they always want to limit somebody else's legislator.
There is the value of experience, but more than that, it's the people's choice whom they want to represent them.
And to arbitrarily say that they can no longer have the representative of their choice is an affront to free government.
I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Are there any questions for Honorable Itza?
Seeing none, actually I have one quick question.
Do you know, is it cumulative or is it in total that you can say the way I read it it would be in total because it doesn't say that it has to be consecutive yeah so it would be in cumulative the other thing I'd like to add is I think that the New Hampshire House is a remarkably diverse body by consequence of the fact that we get paid next to nothing, it requires that everybody in one way or another be a member of the community.
Nobody can come up here and park and make this a career.
They have to be out in the community.
They have to work and be part of it.
Representative Ingerbertson is one of the premier artists in America, former Representative Ingerbertson.
Former Representative Mirsky is an architect.
Former Representative's, I can't remember, he ran for senator, he was my seatmate back in 2006.
I remember sitting there, I'm there, as you all know, I was poor as a church mouse most of my legislative career, and while we're sitting there he sold a building in Romania for $600,000.
I mean, the diversity of the New Hampshire legislature, in my opinion, is nothing short of astounding.
Thank you very much.
Seeing no other pink cards.
And we have the next hearing at 1 o'clock.
I think I can declare an early lunch and and we'll be back at one o'clock and I'll close this hearing on CACR 25.
Thank you.
It's a crapshoot.
The time being one o'clock, I will open the hearing on CACR 31.
Is that right?
26.
How come I have the thing up here for 21?
All right.
Thank you.
How come I have the thing up here for 21?
26.
All right.
This is providing that 100 of the representatives are elected using party list proportional representation.
Prime sponsor is Representative LeBranch, and I think we have Representative LeBranch speak like you to legislative administration again floor is yours thank you chair and thank you again for listening to my testimony today CAC our 26 comes as the United States is facing an era of extreme polarization and extreme toxicity in the political process.
It seems hard to sit down with people who have different political views.
It's broken families.
Even in my own family, there's a lot of political disagreement, and it hurts sometimes to get into those arguments and this bill proposing that we adopt party list proportional representation which is another electoral model to use it's used in other countries such as Germany Finland Israel Scotland and New Zealand and many other countries And this electoral system seeks to increase the political diversity in the legislative body.
Most countries that adopt this system have more than five parties in their legislature.
And this makes it so that no party can have, or makes it very difficult for a party to have, an outright majority.
And it leads to a form of government that leads to more consensus when you have to sit down and negotiate or talk to other parties and other legislatures to get your bills passed and your legislation through.
That's why we see coalition governments in Europe and other countries is because they do have a form of consensus democracy.
And this CACR seeks to start moving towards that direction and building a model based on consensus instead of the current polarized system in which we have.
And there are many different versions of party less proportional representation, and I'm glad and I'm happy to answer questions related to that.
But this CACR just says that we will adopt party list proportional and then if this is adopted, then the legislature would choose what type of party list proportional we would like to adopt.
And I'm happy to answer any questions.
Thank you.
Does anyone on the committee have questions for the representative?
Seeing none I have one question for you.
Can you explain to me how this would work given our current redistricting situation?
How would those hundred be referred to by the speaker when they were coming up to the well for instance?
So I would like to explain it like this.
Obviously proportional representation means if a party receives 5% of the vote, it gets 5% of the seats in the legislature.
And this would basically make New Hampshire an at-large district.
I know that's hard to think about.
It would be a very big district.
But that's how it operates currently in Germany.
where parties through the primary process choose a list of candidates that they would like to be elected depending on the proportion of votes that they get.
So in this case, they would have a list of 100 people that they would like to have represent them in the legislature.
And depending on the amount of votes, the proportion of votes that they receive, let's say they got 5% of the vote, that's 5% of the seats.
Or let's make it easier, they get 4% of the vote, which is about 16 seats in this legislature.
They would get the first 16 people on that list elected.
And I understand with redistricting that makes it more complex.
Either we would have to reapportion those districts or wait until the next redistricting process in 10 years Thank you.
How would it work for county representation?
I'm not sure I understand the question well currently state reps are also county reps.
Yep, right so So how would we apportion those county representation?
I believe these representatives would not be county delegates because there is no mechanism, at least unless we flesh it out when the when this is passed we would have to pass something else that explains what form of party list proportional representation we would want to take.
But I don't see a mechanism being able to say that we need this many people from Hillsborough on the party list or this many people from Merrimack on the county list because there's no way of knowing who's going to get elected on that list.
We don't know before the election if the party's going to get 5%, 50%.
Polling has not been that reliable.
But I would see them not being delegates if this were to pass.
And, and would there not be any way of, um of assuring any representation from a particular area?
Or is it possible that some area may have an extraordinary number of representatives and some other area have virtually none?
You bring up a very good point, and that actually brings me to another point I would like to make in Scotland they have a proportional representation system that is by county which is something that we could adopt instead of making the entire state in at-large district we could make every single county in at-large district so that would mean depending on how many seats Hillsborough County gets that would mean 5% of the Hillsborough County at-large seats would be apportioned to the party that gets that vote.
So there is a way that could be based on county and could be county delegates.
But in the way that I had proposed, it would not.
Right.
This is not by county that you proposed.
If this bill passes, or I should say the CSAR does pass does pass it could be because this just says that we should have proportional representation that is mandated for a hundred seats but it doesn't exactly spell out if it is partyless proportional representation by county or the entire state who would determine who would make that determination the legislature in passing a bill explaining how would we apportion those 100 seats.
There are many, as I said, forms of proportional representation.
There are closed versus open lists.
I would advise that we adopt an open or a closed list.
Closed list means basically that the lists are determined in party primaries, and then those lists are voted on in the general election.
An open list would make it so that any voter could vote in the primary, which is something that New Hampshire currently does not have, so that does not apply to us.
And then there's the compensatory versus non-compensatory system, which basically means out of those 100 seats, are we saying that if you get 5% of the vote, you get 5% of those seats?
Or are we compensating and saying that you get 5% of the seats in the House?
So those would be things that the legislature would have to determine if this constitutional amendment were to pass.
Thank you.
It's a very technical bill so I apologize.
Would there also, so currently we have a number of undeclared or independent voters.
They are currently allowed to declare for a primary and vote in either the Democrat or the Republican.
How would independent under this system, if we went to a closed primary, which I'm hearing we would have to do, it would be the primary that would declare who these people are, if we went that way.
Who would you also be advocating for still allowing independents to declare for a primary?
So closed list is just the technical term that I used.
The primaries would stay the same as they currently are.
Independents could still vote in whatever primary they choose and then unregister afterwards.
So it would be the same process because it would just be another line item on the primary ballot.
So there's no change in moving to a closed primary or an open primary.
It would just stay the same as it currently is.
But the people that are on that list that are voted for, they would have to declare Republican or Democrat, correct?
Yeah, it would be like we currently have in our system where I ran on the Democrat primary ballot.
I was the Democrat candidate in Hillsborough 22, and it would be the same process except either at an at-large statewide or county level.
I see.
Thank you.
I triggered another question.
Thank you, Representative Simonson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
How does one get on the party list?
From my knowledge of New Hampshire law it would be the same exact process as running for state rep currently.
You would just declare that you would want to run for this district instead of whatever district you live in.
So instead of running for Hillsborough 22 I would say in the form that I would like to run for the at-large position.
So up?
Follow up.
So being from Littleton in the frozen north, there's this old saying that if you live in Nashua and Manchester, the state basically stops in Concord, and if you live in Concord, the state basically stops in Plymouth.
If I were in Littleton, fairly unknown to most of the state, and I wanted to run for one of these positions, how would you keep, let's say, larger Republican areas like Salem from basically determining the vast majority of who gets those seats?
Are you centralizing power, essentially, in certain parts of the state and stripping it from others?
Thank you for the question and to answer your question as I answered earlier this just the CACR just says that we would have a proportional system not exactly how we would move forward with that system but we could do it by a county to the county at large districts so So that would be one way of limiting the influence of the very populous south of New Hampshire.
One more.
So even within a county, however, there are more populous areas and less populous areas.
Would we run into the same problem?
And do you have a solution to keep that from happening in your proposal?
Where the vast majority of say the representation in grafting County isn't still in the southern part of the of the county itself?
What keeps the southern part of the county from then garnering the vast majority of the representation and leaving the northern part of the county?
Basically without representation That is a very good question We would still have the normal representative districts that we currently have.
Let me think about that for a second.
Yeah, and you can get back to me at a further time.
I don't expect you have all the answers right now, but just...
I believe I'll send you an email later.
Okay, sounds good.
Thank you.
Nothing further, thank you very much for your testimony.
We have only one other pink card on that.
The Honorable Dan Itza, from Manchester, I believe.
Yes, currently.
Currently.
Thank you, Mr.
Itza.
Chairman, members of the committee.
I am Dan Itza, and I am living in Manchester.
I do rise in opposition to this proposal, and I'm going to use the Constitution to surprise you all.
All power residing originally in and being derived from the people, all the magistrates of government, are their substitutes and agents and at all times accountable to them.
One of the things that this would create is effectively unaccountable representatives.
One of the things that happens when you have large districts is that the the individual in office is accountable to so many people that they are effectively unaccountable.
When in the convention for the Constitution for the United States, George Washington made one comment.
He said 30,000 is representation referring to the House of Representatives.
30,000 is representation, 50,000 is tyranny.
The point being that the more constituents you have, the less accountable you become.
And this would create a cadre of a hundred representatives who are elected by vast numbers of people.
Nobody would be likely to be following their voting record or anything.
They would be effectively unaccountable.
It also has, I guess you'd say, an unintended consequence that you then have the remaining 300 reps who are apportioned among the towns and city wards.
So instead of having a representative for every 3,400 people or whatever it is right now you would quickly jump to something more like 5,000 or 5,500 people in an instant.
And it would mean a lot of towns, a number of towns would lose their individual representation, which we enjoy.
And it's that level of representation that has made New Hampshire number one in personal and economic freedom, which was recently awarded this year, because we have a level of representation that is commensurate with the founding period of the United States.
We would be giving up something very near and dear.
When you look at areas like Littleton, I think Kowalsk County has about 10 representatives.
Now this is one quarter of the legislature.
If you did it by county, they get two of those representatives, the party affiliated or party list representatives.
How do you divide them between three parties?
You have a third of the state approximately which is unaffiliated with any political party.
Do they get representation?
Not on a party list scheme or do we have or do we call independent voters, unaffiliated voters now their own party which is kind of a backward way of thinking.
I mean totally backward, they're a party because they're not a party.
I don't think it's a good idea and I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there any questions?
One by Representative Rullard.
Thank you for taking my question.
The question I have is how will the people in this state know what they're voting for when this is put on the ballot?
Public education classes, I don't know.
It is so disparate from anything in our political experience where our politics have been extremely local, where the average person can bump into their state rep in the grocery store.
It would be a disconnection of the legislature from their constituents.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Seeing none, thank you.
Thank you.
We are out of pink cards.
We started this at 1 o'clock.
Our next hearing is at 2 o'clock.
Smoke them if you got them.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
When we go to the well, we are.
So two o'clock has arrived.
That means we can jump into our other representative silver bill, CACR 27, which is providing that all state court judges shall be subject to recall and removal by petition and vote of registered voters pursuant to provisions established by the legislature.
Chair would welcome Representative Silver to provide testimony.
Welcome.
Thank you Mr Chairman, and thank you to the members of the committee.
The issue...
Excuse me, can you remind us where you are?
I'm sorry, I'm a state representative from Belknap County District 2, towns of Guilford and Meredith, and I live in Guilford.
Thank you.
And this is my second non-consecutive term.
The issue being addressed by this is an issue brought to my attention by various and sundry constituents who complain with all sorts of stories and horror stories, complaints about their treatment by judicial officers in the court system in the state, most of whom are complaining about how they're treated in family court.
Some in divorce situations, some dealing with child custody, child removals, DCYF stuff that's going on, etc cetera, whatever.
So basically, I did some research, and I looked into how do we deal with judges?
How do judges get appointed, and how long do they serve, and how do we get rid of them if we want to?
So as we probably know, judges are appointed by the governor and then confirmed by the executive council.
And once they're confirmed by the executive council, which probably rubber stamps most of the judicial appointments, I would assume, they serve until they age out at age 70.
So we end up with a situation, for example, which is a story for another day, basically, but a side story, where you have an excellent Chief Justice of our state Supreme Court, Bob Lynn, who aged out, but now we're fortunate enough that we brought him back as a state representative.
That's a different story.
So in the history of our state, the only way, or the current law is the only way that a judge can be removed from office is by the process of impeachment.
Impeachment is a drastic remedy, almost never attempted to be used, and in the history of our state has only been used a very few times, probably less than the fingers on one hand.
So I looked into how other states have dealt with this issue.
I have a handout which I'll give to all the representatives that basically provides, does a sort of a recap of all the abilities of states that have provisions for the recall of government officials and officers.
Right now, there are 40 states that have law provisions allowing for the recall of officials.
And there's a whole variety of ways.
There's specific provisions.
This gives a detail, literally state by state by state, which states have provisions.
I recall a number of years ago, there was a Chief Justice of the California Supreme Court who came under fire because she never would approve lower court's imposition of the death penalty.
And she had several members of the court sided with her.
And this stirred up a hornet's nest.
And California, I guess we all know, is notorious for doing recalls.
They recalled governors in the past.
Sometimes they have been successful, sometimes not.
But in the case of Rose Bird, who was the chief justice out in California, she and some of her acolytes on the Supreme Court were in fact recalled and replaced.
So there's different ways of dealing with the issue.
Right now, the citizens of our state have basically, essentially, no practical way to remove judges whose behavior they might think is improper, but doesn't rise to this supreme level that might justify impeachment and might actually be successful at impeachment.
So essentially we have a situation with state court judges, many of whom are excellent, but some of whom are not so excellent.
But neither category of those judges has any responsibility, or they're not responsible to the people of the state who pay their salaries through taxes and who then have to subject themselves to going before them for adjudication of their rights.
So what the CACR 27 does, it provides in the Constitution that state court judges shall be subject to recall and removal by petition and vote of the registered voters pursuant to provisions which the general court has to, once this would be passed, then implementing legislation would need to be adopted by the general court.
So the specifics.
And so what I'd like to do, if I might, is to pass out this reprint of the summary of the laws governing recall.
May I, Mr.
Chair?
Certainly.
recall may I mr.
chair certainly Wikipedia Wikipedia?
No, no, this is Ballotpedia.
This is Ballotpedia.
And just once, you know, if it's on the internet, it must be true.
We all know that, right?
So here's some extras for those that didn't show.
In case they actually want to read it.
So basically, that's it.
It basically puts a provision in the Constitution that gives a pathway for the removal of judges short of impeachment.
It's pretty simple.
And then we have to figure out the actual mechanics, looking at how it's been done in other states.
There's different combinations and permutations of how the different states have done it.
And that's basically it.
So I'm open for questions.
Thank you very much for your testimony.
I see one question.
Representative.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you for your testimony today, Representative.
Are you aware that in New Hampshire we have the Judicial Conduct Committee?
Yes.
Follow up, Mr.
Chairman?
Absolutely.
Are you aware that anybody can file a complaint with the Judicial Conduct Committee?
Yes.
Follow up.
Why is it that you would go to a recall and overstep anything that the Judicial Conduct Committee does?
I'm not familiar with the exact makeup of the Judicial Conduct Committee.
I'm assuming that it is comprised either exclusively or substantially by either other judges or lawyers or a combination thereof.
So to some extent, it's the guild mentality that protects its own, I believe.
That would would be my feeling and that's the feeling of many of my constituents that you know if a problem if they have a problem with a judge and raise a complaint the the judges and lawyers in the state sort of gather around and circle the wagons and try to be very protective of the judges and I'm'm not sure, I haven't looked into what actions have been taken by the Judicial Conduct Committee, but I have not heard of very many judges being removed or suspended or anything like that.
I could just admit that I don't have any numbers on that, and maybe they have done so.
But all this does is it places not in some committee that meets in secret, but it puts in the hands of the voters the ability to do this.
It wouldn't be an easy process.
It's not an easy process.
As witnessed, the California recall, the recent recall attempts of their governor, which failed.
They had a recall, and it failed.
So it's not an easy process.
There are alternatives to this process.
I discussed with one of the lobbyists while we were on break.
There is what's called the Missouri Plan, which is that judges who go through the appointment process assume the mantle of being a judge, that every six years or some other specific term have to run in an election before the voters, what's called a retention election, that says, shall justice so-and-so be retained, yes, no.
And when those have been held in many states, it's very unusual that a judge actually gets removed under a Missouri plan retention vote.
But it's available that's just an alternative but this is this is something basically putting in the hands of the voters my constituents who are very upset about their treatment in the judicial system and I say that as a member of the bars of New Hampshire and Florida.
Representative Spedia.
Thank you Mr.
Chair and thank you for your testimony.
So, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for your testimony.
So would, just like, you know, we had a special, if it was a recall election, would that fall into the kind of similar rules that the special elections would go under?
I'm sorry?
If it's, you know, if it's a recall, we had to recall somebody.
We got the petitions and we're going to recall them.
Does that election then go before like a special election?
The Executive Council makes the decision?
It would be based, the specific procedure would have to be set forth in an RSA that we have to adopt if this constitutional amendment, because the constitutional amendment says the procedures have to be set by the general court.
So we can set it.
Now, I don't think it would, personally, I don't think it would be a good idea to have a recall election of a judge mixed in with a town election or a general election, etc.
Sounds to me, would seem to me be more reasonable to have it as a special election, but that's really up to the general court to decide in implementing legislation.
So the answer is, I don't, you know, nothing is decided, it will be decided later.
Senator Roulard.
Thank you.
What's the process in New Hampshire right now for removal of a judge?
Impeachment.
How many impeachments have we had in the state of New Hampshire?
Two.
Two?
Thank you.
I was aware of one, I thought it was two.
Dan, he says it's two.
Follow up.
And do you know how one or both actually came to fruition?
Well, if you don't know the answer, just say you don't know.
Yeah, we'll wait until you- I don't know the answer, but I thought it was one or two.
Representative Itzi, former Representative Itzi, is really the constitutional scholar and stuff like this, and is sort of the font of knowledge.
Thank you.
Thank you Any I have a couple of questions if you don't mind So I'm looking on on the bottom of Well, I guess it's just the first page of this on line 27, and it talks about the governor with consent of the council may remove any commissioned officer for reasonable cause upon the address of both houses of the legislature.
That's not the impeachment that we're talking about, correct?
Correct.
Do you know what the reasonable cause, if that's defined anywhere?
Probably not.
It's sort of like in the federal Constitution impeachment for high crimes and misdemeanors and the courts have said it's whatever Congress says it means.
Whenever you have those things, things like reasonable cause or cause or just cause, it's whatever the governing body who's applying it says it means.
Because it does go on further.
It says, shall not be a cause which is sufficient ground for impeachment.
Right.
So it's a separate remedy.
Separate from impeachment.
So that's different than the impeachment that you said would be the only remedy, correct?
Correct.
So I stand correct.
So there is an alternative remedy, but what I'm providing now is another alternative remedy.
Okay.
What I'm wondering about is the wording of the voter's guide to implement this CACR.
It's it's basically asking the people if they would agree that the legislature should make up rules on this.
Yes.
Correct?
Correct.
Yes.
It's not outlining what those rules or what those people, what judges or commissioned officers would be removed for.
It's only saying, should we create a process for this to happen?
Correct.
It's up to the general court to do implementing legislation.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Any further anywhere?
No.
Thank you again for your testimony.
Thank you for your attention.
Next up would be...
Help me with this.
Richard Garingo.
you tell me.
How's that?
I will.
I'm used to it.
It's a hard name.
Thank you.
My name is Richard Guerriero.
I'm an attorney here in New Hampshire.
I have offices in Keene and in Concord and the reason I'm here today is that I'm the president of the New Hampshire Bar Association.
So I'm speaking on behalf of the Bar Association.
Welcome to Legi Admin.
I think the first thing I will tell you is that, you know, our Bar Association has over 5,000 active attorneys.
And we have a legislation committee that studies legislation like this.
and we a Board of Governors that represents all of those attorneys both from particular counties and at large and I wanted to tell you that our legislation committee unanimously opposes this effort CA CR 27 and the Board of Governors although we got kind of late, every member that I was able to get to vote last night, almost all of them, they all voted unanimously in opposition of this.
So if you take nothing else away from what I say, the New Hampshire Bar Association strongly opposes this proposal, okay?
Now the reasons for that are pretty straightforward.
We see this as an effort that would politicize judicial decisions and court cases and we think that that is not proper judges should I think all of us would agree decide cases on the law and the facts and if judges are thinking about or pressured by efforts to remove them from office because of their actions in particular cases, that will politicize their position, which is not what our Constitution intends.
It is important that there be remedies for the isolated cases where judges are far out of line.
The normal remedy, which we all know about and you all know about, is you appeal the decision.
You appeal to the Supreme Court and they correct that decision and we have good Supreme Court justices.
That's how we correct those decisions.
Where you have instances of misconduct by a judge, we do have the Judicial Conduct Committee and that is very active.
I mean frankly, you don't have to go beyond the front pages of the union leader in the last six or eight months to know that the Judicial Conduct Committee is active and in contact with the attorney general.
And when a judge is out of line, they do take the necessary action.
In regard to the comments earlier, I did want to note for you because, I mean, honestly, I would be concerned if the Judicial Conduct Committee was all lawyers, and I would feel like it was inside baseball.
But I know it's not all lawyers because as president of the bar, I just appointed a non-lawyer.
And number two, if you look at the makeup, I'll just read there.
There's one public member and one alternate member appointed by the president of the New Hampshire Bar Association who is not a judge, attorney, clerk of court, or elected or appointed public official.
The Supreme Court appoints, again, another member who is not an attorney, judge, etc.
The governor appoints two public members.
The president of the Senate appoints one, and the speaker of the House appoints one.
So the non-attorney public is substantially represented on the Judicial Conduct Committee.
And I don't want to go on forever, but the bottom line is we feel like through the appeal process and through the Judicial Conduct Committee, these concerns are all adequately addressed.
There's no reason to politicize the role of judges.
You know, that would go against the framework that is set up in the Constitution, that judges are supposed to be appointed, they're appointed for life or until 70 for a reason, so they can make decisions without political pressure and follow the law and the facts and not be subject to that kind of influence.
And the last thing I will note, I didn't intend to add this, but I'll add, I mean, there is a significant vetting process.
I mean, just to speak plain English about it, I mean, Chuck Douglas is on the Judicial Selection Commission.
He runs that.
Only people that get through that are people that are fair and reasonably competent, and they're going to do the job that they're supposed to do.
And then almost every nominee comes before the Board of Governors at the Bar Association, and we issue a recommendation.
And it's not true that they're a rubber stamp.
In fact, we issued a recommendation earlier this year where we recommended that the person was qualified with reservations, and that person ended up withdrawing their application to be a judge before the Executive Council.
So it's not a rubber stamp.
Thank you.
with reservations and that person ended up withdrawing their their application to be a judge before the executive council so it's not a rubber stamp and we think the process works fine the way it is so I'll take any questions you have thank you for your testimony are there questions yes representative Simon thank you mr.
chair thank you for taking my question just for those of us who don't know, the Judicial Conduct Committee, you say that it will take the necessary actions for whatever's happening.
What is the scope of that?
What might be the ramifications if a judge steps out of line from the board's perspective?
Well, I mean, it is true that it would have to go to impeachment if it got that far.
I mean, as a practical matter, and it's just honestly just my recollection and recent experience if it gets to a certain point where the judge is being severely disciplined they typically resign you know if they're sanctioned in some way but I think that I mean ultimately the New Hampshire Supreme Court has authority there and then and so you know the Judicial Conduct Committee can make a recommendation, take actions, take the person off a particular case, reprimand the judge or whatever and I think refer it for impeachment.
Thank you.
Further questions?
So I have a couple.
So you mentioned how some of the non-public people are appointed to that commission.
How many total do they represent out of the?
I honestly can't answer that way.
I don't remember the number right now.
I mean, I could literally look it up for you.
We can supplement it.
But if you said you thought it was, and it seems like it's probably half and half.
It may be slightly heavier towards judges and lawyers.
I honestly don't remember the numbers.
Okay.
I would grant you that it's influenced by the, somebody probably looked at that.
I would grant you that.
I mean, look, it's a judicial conduct committee with a bunch of judges and attorneys on it.
They have a heavy influence I would grant that.
Okay.
So the average age that someone would be first appointed as a judge is that is there is it 30s 40s 50s?
You know I don't know the average age I mean I it's just my personal experience that most governors try to appoint people where their appointment will be on the bench for a while.
But just in the last, we've had, at least in my experience, an extraordinary number of judicial appointments this year.
I think the Bar Association has vetted 15 or 16 people, which is more than the entire five or six years before that.
and I think the Bar Association has vetted 15 or 16 people, which is more than the entire five or six years before that.
And I think one of them was early 40s.
And one of the recent ones we vetted, which I was kind of surprised, he was over 60.
I was like, well, you're going to appoint him on the bench for seven or eight years.
But, you know, I don't make the appointments.
We just say whether or not they're qualified.
So it's a pretty big range but if you said you know late 40s early 50s I think that'd be about right.
Okay.
Does that, so that means that you know if we said 50 theoretically they would be there for 20 years which would sound about right to you I guess yeah and during that time period they have essentially free reign aside from the Judicial Conduct Committee is that fair?
Well and the appeal of, which is really important.
The appeal of their decisions to another court.
Right.
So, and that's, you know, I mean, that's...
But that's their decision rather than their profession.
You mean in terms of personal misconduct or something like that?
Yes, that's right.
Okay.
And so that's really what the prime sponsor is trying to address, is that personal conduct rather than their actions?
Is that fair to say?
I'm not asking you to...
I think that's probably right.
I mean, it's also my experience.
I mean, the reality is that some of the most painful cases that people have to deal with in court are custody cases and divorce cases, and that's why a lot of these complaints arise.
And you should also, I mean, the Professional Conduct Committee for Lawyers gets a huge number of complaints against lawyers handling divorce cases because people are so upset and feelings are running so deep.
And I totally understand that depth of that reaction when it comes to custody and divorce and that sort of thing.
But I do think it's telling that you don't see those complaints so much in other areas of the law.
And so it makes me think that this is really more attributable to the emotional nature and the importance, you know, personally for people of those cases than some systemic problem with judges.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Is it your belief that the states that do have this type of recall provision are more politicized because of that?
It is.
And I will speak from personal experience it's I hate to say it but ancient personal experience I came here from Louisiana so I've been practicing here almost 30 years and I've been practicing almost 40 years the first eight or nine ten years I practiced in Baton Rouge and New Orleans and I had a private practice where we were in a system with elected judges and you know I'm not saying there is anything morally wrong or terrible about that but I can tell you I didn't like it when somebody was running for judge asking me for money in a political campaign and we I felt like I'm going to be appearing in front of these judges I have to give money and honestly I'll tell you exactly what I did it's so old I gave the same amount to every viable candidate if there was an opening I'll just give a pick how much I had and I would divide it and I'd give the same amount to each one because I couldn't think of anything else to do.
It just seems like to me it has no place in the judicial process.
We should appoint a person who's competent, who has the integrity and the ability, and represents the community in a way that they can apply the law to the facts and be above politics.
And I think if we go down this road, if we started having elections related to judges, judges then you're not gonna you're gonna have that politicization of the process thank you for your testimony any one one final sure um so just looking at the bill in front of us I see it as basically being dealing more with the pulling people out of their positions rather than how a new person would be reinstated.
So as far as the political, I mean, I could be reading that incorrectly, but it's you know, taking a judge who's showing misconduct, taking them out of their position.
I don't think anything's been said.
Am I incorrect as far as how they'd be reinstated?
I thought it authorized the general court to create a process.
Well, we would be creating a process, right.
So my question is, in your testimony at the end there, you had said in cases where states hold elections and people are asking for financial funds, would you feel more comfortable, not that you feel comfortable with it, but do you think it would be just as politicized if the governor would then reappoint another person, let's say, and it would have to be approved by the executive council, but it wouldn't actually go to the public for a vote.
I think there's a whole host of unanswered questions there.
So, I mean, here's an example.
Suppose there's a recall election or a vote for a judge.
Does that judge have a First Amendment right to campaign and say, I should not be recalled?
And then do voters have a First Amendment right to donate to that judge?
And then, so then what about litigants and lawyers who donate to that?
I mean, it's just a can of worms, to be frank about it.
That, for good reason, I think the Bar Association opposes it, and I'm one of those on the Board of Governors who voted to oppose it for that kind of reason.
It's just, haven't dealt with, and I think we shouldn't deal with it.
And even if it's only on the recall and not on the vote on the replacement, how do you avoid these issues that come up?
And any time you say the voters are going to come out and vote, then the voters have rights, and the person who is involved in the vote has rights, and you involve other constitutional provisions, the First Amendment and due process.
And, I mean, the only thing I could say, it might be more work for attorneys, which I'm not sure you're in the business of endorsing.
So, you know.
No, thank you for that clarification.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
That's all I see.
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you.
I did submit written testimony as well you did okay thank you great thank you very much last pink card that I see here is Honorable Dan it's a who's still from Manchester thank you sir and speaking in in support of the bill.
And that support is questionable for a lot of the reasons just voiced to the politics and the election nature for a judge.
But there are two reasons I really wanted to testify.
One was as to the Judicial Conduct Committee.
And they cannot do really anything more than sanction a judge.
They can give them a vacation, they can fine them, but they cannot take them out of play per se.
They can't remove them from office.
Even the Supreme Court can't remove them from office.
There's only one body that can remove them from office right now, and that's the legislature.
The two provisions for removal from office.
One is, as you know, impeachment.
That is for actions in your office.
Bribery, corruption, malpractice, or maladministration in office.
So in the conduct of their duties.
And that's primarily what you'd be seeing here because you've got, you know, these are because people feel they've been aggrieved, denied due process, whatever in the judicial process.
That applies to any officer of the state and so it doesn't have to be a commissioned officer.
In my opinion it could float down to the towns, which are political subdivisions of the state.
Why would the legislature allow an evil person to remain as a selectman or whatever, who was abusing the people?
The other method of removal is Bill of Address.
Bill of Address is limited to commissioned officers.
So it applies to certain of the department heads, it applies to judges, military officers, and it says in there, as Representative Hill correctly pointed out, that it is for those things for which you cannot be impeached.
So it's for actions outside of your office.
It might be for womanizing or drunkenness.
I can't remember the particular offices involved, but at the time I think it was sheriff, and then the person got a gubernatorial commission and this is like in the 1950s and they were removed by bill of address from their commissioned office for actions that they executed as sheriff Because it was felt to make them unfit for office So that's that's the interplay over there.
I do think that something needs to be done because in my opinion the family court is a mess.
Yes it does deal with highly emotional situations but the family court has very little in the way of fixed laws within which they operate.
And that has, and yes they have court rules, but the judge has the power to waive those rules in the interest of justice.
So rule one is there are no rules unless the judge wants them.
Thank you.
interest of justice.
So rule one is there are no rules unless the judge wants them.
That has led to a lot of discretionary action.
My efforts as a legislator were to put as much as I could into statute so that that it had to be followed.
I think you need to look at this, I think you need to consider it.
I think there's a lot of issues with this.
If the judge in question is a district court or family court judge that practices in Portsmouth, over what universe do you have the recall election?
Certainly somebody over in Hillsborough County should be voting on it.
Probably somebody in western Rockingham County has no interest in the and the people who would be voting over there have no knowledge of the situation.
So there are a lot of logistical issues that you would have to consider.
I guess that's it I'd happy be happy to take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there questions?
I have one.
So it sounds to me while you're in favor of the concept, you're not convinced that ACACR is the correct pathway?
Or is it more you're not sure that the Judicial Conduct Committee is the correct method of addressing the problems you see in family court or whatever.
Can you clarify that?
Yeah, I can.
One, if you're going to have any method of removal other than impeachment or bill of address you would have to amend the Constitution, that's clear.
I think you would have to have a very well thought out plan before you did that because once you amend the Constitution then you have to take action to execute that amendment.
So even if you wanted to give the Judicial Conduct Committee some extraordinary power to remove judges.
You couldn't do it till you amended the Constitution.
I think the real issue at hand is a greater scrutiny of the courts and that's up to you guys.
Thank you.
By statute or?
Well, the first thing to do, in my opinion, would be to pass a House resolution creating an investigation of the courts.
That's how an impeachment typically initiates, for instance.
You create a committee.
This is from, okay, I was not yet in the House, but I was in politics at the time of the Brock situation.
It began as a bill of address, which it really shouldn't have been because everything was in the course of duties, but the bill of address raised enough issues that the House passed a resolution to investigate the situation.
That investigation turned up the issues that justified or instigated the impeachment.
And that was the other, the two impeachments.
One was Justice Brock in 1998 I believe, 98-99 99.
And the other one was, I believe, in 1794.
It was a judge who had been elected to Congress, which is an incompatible office, and he was refusing to resign his judgeship, which he held by Constitution until 70.
And when the impeachment got lodged, he he resigned and it all went away.
But you're you're describing situations where it has worked already through the legislature by a bill of address.
Well really it should be by impeachment and you do it first by passing a resolution to investigate.
But again through the legislature.
Through the legislature.
That's actually particularly through the House of Representatives.
The House of Representatives is styled as the grand inquest.
You would also call it the grand jury of the state.
So it's the House who has the duty to investigate actions of the judiciary or members of the executive as to whether or not there's anything to impeach for and if they find it then it would they be they who introduced the bill of impeachment which is the indictment which then goes before the Senate to convict or not.
But all of that is done without any changes made to the Constitution.
Absolutely.
So is a constitutional amendment necessary in order to get at?
Absolutely not.
Just requires resolve.
So you were in favor of it before you were against it?
Well, this is a different issue.
This is giving the people, would give the people a path to take should they not be able to inspire their representatives to protect them from government.
And where does the redress of grievances come in on this?
That's entirely separate.
Okay, okay.
I'm set.
Anyone, did I stir up anything?
No?
sorry thank you for your testimony look at that I have no other pink cards does everyone have any other things to say no good closing the hearing then on 27 and we can jump immediately into CACR 29, which is providing that the number of representatives to be no more than 150 and the number of senators be no more than 35.
And for that I have one.
Do we have a, oh, yep, we have the prime sponsor, who is Representative Connolly before us.
Welcome to the legislative administration.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, committee members.
Casey Connolly, State Representative from Dover.
I represent Stratford County District 13.
And here now to talk about CACR 29.
So before I start, I should say that I have the utmost respect for this body.
But we're talking about changing it, so it's that this is an improvement this is not meant as a criticism of the process or any member or anything like that this is truly about one person's thought about how it could be improved so that's the that's the preamble so like I said this is about good government it's about raising the bar for public service in New Hampshire.
And it's about paying legislators for their time.
This is work, and it should be treated that way and compensated as such.
The CACR would fairly significantly restructure the size of the legislature.
The title of the bill represents an old version.
It's actually no more than 200 is what's contemplated under this bill.
This was a revision during the drafting process So anyway, so that just so I'm clear the title has not changed but the The guts of the bill has changed mr.
Chairman, that's correct That was I don't know if that's an oversight or if that's the standard process but the title did not evolve when the text of the bill changed.
I see yeah I see it on so everyone's aware on line 8 of the bill no more than 200.
Anyway continuing with that thread so instead So instead of 400 seats, there'd be 200.
Instead of 24 Senate seats, there'd be 35.
Currently, there's about one representative for every 3,400 residents of our state.
And roughly one for Senator for every 57,000 people under this proposal would be about 6,800 residents per house member, 39,000 or so residents per senator.
So still pretty representative and very similar to states on both sides of us, Maine, Vermont, as far as that ratio.
So I do this, as I said earlier, it's about raising the bar and raising the standard for for this house on any session day there are anywhere between 10 and 20 percent of our members not present we have committee members who never show up ever there are or when i first ran for this seat i did so in a special election because nobody else wanted to in my district in Dover.
We have seats across the state that nobody signs up for, period.
And this is every election every year, and not just in one-party control seats.
And it would reduce the number of bad bills.
And by bad, I don't mean bills I don't agree with.
I mean bills that aren't fully formed, weren't thought through um bills that all of us see repeatedly at our committees that um end up in the consent calendar 21 to 0 against and i would allow members to get to know one another potentially reducing the rancor it's easy to um it's a little easier to misbehave when you're in a group of 400.
If you know the members and you have some personal experience with them, it's a lot harder to, frankly, act, to see what we saw at the last House session, to be real honest.
And it would reduce the influence of lobbyists because members would have a chance to gain some expertise in more than one subject.
So along those same lines, this work should not be a hobby.
It should not be a volunteer job.
Under the current structure, $100 a year makes it so that vast swaths of our state, they can't even run for this, let alone serve, because they have to work, they have family.
What is contemplated here is a pretty nominal salary, $6,000 for House members, 7,500 for senators.
That's roughly based on $25 an hour for roughly 200 hours of work.
So that's where that came from.
That would still be one of the lowest salaries in the country.
It's not enough to make a career out of.
It's about, again, paying people for their work.
And I think this is work.
It's important work.
And it should be compensated as such.
So with that, I'll stop.
I think residents might be open to this.
And I think we should give them a chance to hear it and vote on it.
So thank you to the committee and Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for your testimony.
Do I see any questions?
I have one.
Representative Green.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Given what our current committee workload is with all our standing committees, how would reducing the body down to 200 representatives, for example, how do you think that would affect the distribution of the workload in committees?
What would be the effect of that?
Thank you for the question.
So I think, first of all, if we've got 780-odd bills this term, I think you could expect it would drop by maybe 40% since not every member does bills.
So you'd see fewer bills, and you'd see a comparable reallocation of members to committees.
So instead of 21 on a committee, which is a fairly large number relative to other legislative bodies in the country, you might see 15, 13.
You know, you would have to look at the numbers, but I think it could be done without any sort of interruption.
Done?
Anything else?
No?
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you all.
Next up, we have Representative Klein Knight.
Welcome to legislative administration.
Thank you so much, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you.
I'm a representative Klein Knight represent Manchester Hillsborough district 11.
I don't want to repeat everything that representative Conley said, but I'm just going to point out some key facts.
This would promote more competition.
So we maybe have a higher standard and caliber of talent.
We'd have less bills and redundancy.
I know that we see a lot of the same bills just with different titles, and that can slow down our workload.
We'll have less obstruction.
We'll have to be more accountable to the relationships we build because we would be a smaller body.
There'd be more bipartisanship.
And it would open the door for more than just the independently wealthy and the retired to also serve and represent their people.
That's it.
Thank you.
Will you take questions if there are any?
Sure.
Are there any?
Representative Dispedia.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Nicole, and thank you, Casey.
Sorry, Representative Connolly, Representative Klein, I should have actually given this question towards Representative Connolly, but do you think, just thinking out loud, do you think that elections would get a little bit more expensive because there's less seats, or do you think there would still be, I mean, like representative connolly said there there is like you know sometimes we struggle to find people to even run so like what do you think about you know if we cut the legislature in half how do you think that affect elections it depends um what district you're in obviously there's a lot of small districts in our state where people run unopposed or they can't even find somebody so in that instance you wouldn't be spending obviously any money there um in some of the more populated areas like the cities like manchester you'll see more uh contested races more challenging races which will uh you, encourage people to raise more funds.
But when you cut the number of representatives obviously running, there's going to be obviously less money spent on local elections.
Thank you.
One further.
Are you not concerned about the reduction in representation?
Not at all.
I believe we have the third largest democracy in the entire world.
We don't need that for a state.
It's comparable to countries like India.
And when you have too much of something, as the saying goes, too many cooks in the kitchen, the soup gets spoiled.
Thank you.
One pink card.
Honorable Dan Itza, who is opposed to the bill.
Vehemently.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
I'm still Dan Itza.
I still reside in Manchester.
I think reducing the number of legislators in the House of Representatives is a really bad idea.
It decreases the amount of representation, it decreases the ability of individuals to know their legislators, it will increase the cost of a lot of the elections, which will increase the influence of lobbyists.
It, you know, a statement was made, too many cooks are spoiling the broth.
Well, in a state that was just judged by the Cato Institute with the highest degree of personal liberty and economic, highest degree of economic liberty, that doesn't sound like a spoiled broth to me and I can't imagine why anybody would want to mess with that I served here for 18 years and during that time there was not an issue with people not knowing each other.
There was not an issue with rancor.
That I suggest is not an issue of the size of the body.
It has to do with how people are getting along.
I served until 2018 And I've talked with people about how much less collegiality there is since I've left I think that's probably more in effect of COVID than it is an effect of the legis the size of the legislature you're not meeting the way you used to you're not not meeting as frequently.
A lot of your committee, I mean, committee meeting attendance was never an issue for the entire time I was here.
If the idea of half the committee or a third of the committee not being here, you wouldn't have seen that four years ago.
You had no trouble filling the committee rooms.
It was not a problem, and it's not the size of the legislature that's causing that problem.
As to increasing the number of senators, I don't know if that's a bad idea.
They've always complained that they were overworked.
Since that number was set, the size of the state has increased dramatically.
Increasing the level of representation in the Senate might not be a bad idea.
I suspect that I would work with that number to make sure that it it a portioned among the people well and how you how it would play out as to Getting making sure all of the counties got more representation and not just a few of them If you decrease the number of the house from 400 to 200, that means a lot of towns that now enjoy their own representative won't anymore.
And that's one of the great things about New Hampshire.
As to only rich people can be in this body, well, I've never been rich.
A lot of the years I was here, I only made $17,000 or thereabouts, certainly less than 25.
I remember Greg Saltz who he delivered Coke, Coca-Cola, sorry, didn't want to mislead anybody there.
He did night deliveries so that he could attend to the general court during the day.
He was certainly not a rich man and he made it work.
I know people who've gotten their employers to allow them the time off and they shift their work to the weekends.
One of the great things about being in New Hampshire is basically anybody who has a situation they can work, it's an affordable and achievable goal.
During most of my career I made sure I never had to spend enough to report to the Secretary of State.
And that would end.
I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Questions?
Seeing none, I have one.
So my question is under the analysis of this CACR, it said all changes will take effect after the 2024 election.
What what would that do to redistricting that we've just spent an enormous Thank you.
the 2024 election.
What would that do to redistricting that we've just spent an enormous amount of time?
You would probably have to re-redistrict and I suspect that...
And is that not a constitutional requirement?
Yeah you'd you'd have to make provision in that amendment to have a single redistricting after the adoption of the amendment.
Much if you look at the language of the original districting in 1784, they had to do that and and there had to be some comment made when we changed the way districts were made in 2006 I believe we adopted the amendment and we had to make provision for when that would be affected this This would probably be cleaner if you just made it take effect in 2030 or 2032.
All right.
Thank you.
Any further?
Are we good to go?
Thank you very much, Honorable Itza.
I think, oh, I see it one more pink card.
Chair recognizes Alvin C.
who would like to speak on this bill.
Welcome to legislative administration.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
My name is Alvin C.
I live in Loudoun and I oppose this bill.
And the one thought I had that really stuck to my mind is Massachusetts now has 160 representatives they used to have a higher number and they had a constitutional amendment at some point and changed it at this point now the speaker of the house only needs to be able to control 80 votes or 80 representatives and that apparently is fairly easy to do with promises of being on a certain committee or committee chairmanships and next in line to be chair and other things like that that he can promise plus the fact that they with a larger population Massachusetts already has much larger house districts so it's harder for people to get around and just run it happen to run into their representatives so in this regard I think this would be a poor idea as far as the Senate going to more than 24, a bigger number is probably not a problem.
But to a certain extent, having two bodies that are elected based on population is kind of redundant.
The Senate used to be based on counties.
And it was because of some of the federal requirements of, of having one man, one vote for all state offices that ended up got ended.
So I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Do we have any questions?
I think you're good to go.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
No other pink cards.
I think I can close the hearing on CACR 29 and we've got two minutes before we start 31.
Thank you.
Thank you, Chair, and hello again, Legislative Administration Committee.
As you all know, my name is Representative LeBranch, and I represent the town of Amherst, New Hampshire.
I'm here today to introduce CACR 31, which seeks to lower the age requirement to run for state senate from age 30 to 25.
There are many reasons why I'm bringing forward this bill.
First of all, let's start off with the fact that under the United States Constitution, 25 year olds may run and serve in the United States House of Representatives.
This means that the founding fathers of the United States entrusted 25 year olds with voting on our national budget and to vote on declarations of war.
This means that we trust 25-year-olds to vote on declaring war and voting on our multi-trillion dollar budget, but not being a New Hampshire state senator.
Secondly, New Hampshire is actually an outlier.
44 states in the United States have lower age requirements than we do, meaning lower than 30.
We are unique in having such a high requirement.
Lastly, we should allow voters to choose the representatives and to judge maturity.
Many other countries do not have age requirements to run for office because of this reason.
It does not make much sense to me that we should have an artificial barrier for voters choosing their representatives.
With that, I ask that the committee pass this bill, ought to pass, and thank you.
I will take any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Are there any questions from the committee?
I have one.
Representative Rula.
Hi.
thanks for taking the question how many state representatives in the house are there now that are age under 30 or actually I should say age 25 current I don't have that number on hand but I could definitely find that out and send that for in an email to you.
Thanks.
So I have a question.
It you said recently in your testimony that you are against the artificial barrier or arbitrary barrier I think and yet in a priorACR, we were talking about 15 years, 15 terms being a barrier.
So how do we rectify the two?
One artificial barrier is good, one isn't.
So I would like to just say that it is a good comparison.
and is an artificial barrier, and it was my understanding that we are against artificial barriers, and this is one of those.
That previous bill was more of a request from a constituent, and I do believe 30 years is a long time to be in this house.
So that was one of the reasons, but the age requirement seems a little bit more arbitrary in this case, just because age is not a dictation of maturity.
I, myself, just turning 20, am sitting here today to testify.
So I guess if I'm answering that question correctly.
Sure.
Thank you for your testimony.
The other question I had is why we're okay with the age limit for House of Representatives but not the Senate.
That's primarily your concern at this point, right?
So the nuance here is that it's the United States House of Representatives that has an age limit of 25.
Obviously, the United States House of Representatives deals with impeachment.
It deals with the national budget.
It deals with matters of war, while the state senate deals with judicial appointments and other appointments and such business as the senate does consider.
I believe what I'm trying to point out is that we trust 25-year-olds with matters of life and death and trillion dollar budgets, but do not trust them with the state to New Hampshire and the matters that we deal with.
Great.
Okay.
Thank you very much for your testimony.
There is no others.
Thank you again.
I see another pink card.
Yeah, well, um, representative Klein Knight.
I also see a senator Whitley.
No.
Thank you.
Senator Klein Knight, you're.
I am just a humble state rep, but sorry.
Humble.
Thank you, members of this committee and chairman.
I am my own state rep.
I differ from a lot of opinions from the last representative that spoke, especially in regards to term limits, because of some of the reasons I mentioned, given my last testimony.
And I do believe that it corresponds directly with this bill in terms of mentorship and passing along knowledge that is institutional.
and if we put an age on that then we may lose some really valuable teachers that can pass the torch to the younger representatives or senators and for that matter I just want to point out that Only five states have the 30 age requirement and nine states out of 50 have 18 as their age requirement and the median for the entire country is 21 to 25.
So we would be on par with the rest of the country if you take a look at the figures.
So with that, I think that I agree with everything Representative LeBranche spoke on.
I do believe that keeping the age at a 30 minimum is a little ageist, and I think we should see a change to align with the rest of the country.
Thank you.
Would you accept questions if there are any?
Sure.
There is one from Representative Simon.
Sorry, I probably should have asked Representative LeBranche this question as well, but I recognize that as a general rule, we're an outlier on this and that the age requirements for other places is lower.
Do we know that that's going well in those other places where people have held those positions?
Do you have any data that you could share with us as far as how that's worked out in other places?
Well, I can't speak to the nitty-gritty details of every state.
I can say that because the median age is 21 to 25 for more than all, you know, there's only nine that are lower than that, nine states, and only five states that are at 30 age requirement right now.
So that should point out to us that it is going well, and it has moved other states to change it, and so that's why there's an increase in that number.
Okay, let me try and take another bite of the apple.
I mean, just to follow up on that, I mean, logically, I understand what you're saying from a logical perspective, but as far as if we were to change the law here based off of just the current testimony that we've heard, we would be doing it in faith that it's going well in those other areas, and that could have happened in other states as well.
So my main question would just be do you have any data from any others or could you get us data from any other states that shows that people have held those offices that that has in fact been, that has gone well?
Of course we can get you that data.
We can do that within the next 24 hours.
Thank you so much for that question.
We'll get back to you on that.
But I highly doubt that the majority of the states, whether you're blue or red, would make this change if things were going poorly.
Thank you.
So I guess when you're doing the research on that, what I would like to see is those states that did reduce it down to 25, how many people are actually serving at that age after they've gone to 25?
That's what I would be interested in.
I don't know what going well or going poorly means.
What I'm interested in is, does the change actually create the results that you're suggesting will happen?
Just for a point of clarification, would you be open to data that shows that they're not just staying in those positions, but they're actually going to other institutions of service within the country?
Because I consider that still a win for public service.
No.
You want them to stay in the House?
Sure.
This is a bill to deal with the age change within the Senate in the state.
So what I'm interested in is other places where this age change has taken place because it's been suggested to us that this would allow others to serve in state Senate.
I would like to know if when that change took place whether it in fact did increase the number of people that served from age 25 to 30.
Something like that.
Okay so the number of people increased not retention wise in the office itself.
Okay.
Right.
Representative Espedia.
Thank, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Nicole, once again.
Have you ever heard of a state working to increase the age limit of any position?
No, I have not.
Thanks.
Follow-up.
I want to apologize.
Sometimes my playful nature is a little...
When you were talking, I just didn't want to come across as being disrespectful at all.
Just to clarify my question, one of my concerns would be, and I guess what I was looking for as far as it's going well, do people who hold positions of power at that age end up running into personal conduct issues?
For example, I know that a state representative from my town who is 18 ended up running into trouble where they bought alcohol for underage people while holding office.
That sort of decision-making that we tend to get a little bit better at as we get older, things along those lines are somewhat what I was concerned about.
Thank you for that.
I believe, actually, that presumption is inappropriate because I know a lot of members older than that that have sexually harassed other members and have also violated the code of conduct.
So I believe that age doesn't discriminate with bad behavior.
Thank you for your testimony.
We have no other pink cards.
30 31 Yep, yep, yep, I had it in the actually is Senator Whitley here or representative?
Okay.
Won't be able to make it.
Thank you.
She sent you a text or...
Okay.
So we should just eliminate her card.
Got it.
You're up.
What was your name again?
It's been a good day.
Just going to invoke the law of unintended consequences here.
You're not just increasing, it would not be just decreasing the age of qualification for senators whether or not you advise to put it before the people the qualifications for counselors that's executive counselors shall be the same as for senator so you would also be reducing the age qualification for executive counselors by If the people adopted this Thank you My my question is did is exactly has anyone seen in this anything mentioned on executive counselors?
reference again where where was that oh that is in part two can make me find it again I was scrambling there we go part two article 61 article 60 the funny things you remember.
Yeah, so the ages are...
The governor has a separate stipulation on age which is 30, but the executive councillor's age limit is tied to the senators which I presume stems from the period when, oh couldn't couldn't have Couldn't have I don't know when that was put in.
Yeah So it wasn't from the time when you know because council was made up of reps and no because reps always had a lower age limit I think originally it was 25 so it couldn't have been there.
So it must have been specifically done after that fact.
Yep huh.
Interesting.
Any further?
No you're good.
I'm good.
Thank you very much for your information.
With that we're back in our holding pattern until 3 30 for the last CACR of the day, right?
All right.
Thank you.
I guess I see.
Residency.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well, no.
I can finally not.
Yeah.
that we carry.
So it's this point.
Yeah.
Obviously that wasn't the only issue.
Thank you.
You have to read it.
I get thought of it.
Yeah.
It should be quite frank.
I have no idea.
and learn what he said.
What is it?
And the rest of the department didn't get the plurality.
It should have been majority.
The rest of the conditions are in there who makes the decision.
Right.
Or you do have to do a runoff election or whatever.
Just go back to majority.
It's a problem solved.
One word, change it.
Yeah, I mean, it was a really bad, I think it was a really bad decision.
It was in the air of constitutional convention.
Don't think it was a bad idea.
But it was something that was happening at the time.
You will find that a lot of states at that, but the majority...
So this is 1911.
Yes.
The 20th century.
One of the concerns.
Okay.
Thank you.
So the time being 3 30.
I'm opening the hearing on CACR 33 requesting the prime sponsor, Representative Moffitt.
Please testify.
Welcome to Legislative Administration, Representative Moffitt.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I did submit electronically some testimony earlier.
And I have some written testimony here, which I might refer to.
I'm perhaps a little nervous being up here.
I can understand.
So thank you for putting this in at the end of the day, and so we won't be rushed, and there's a lot of questions.
So anyway, this proposed measure, CACR 33, as you know, seeks to enable New Hampshire legislature to create a procedure permitting citizens to remove an elected official before the end of a term of office.
Now, this is the same proposal that some of you may recall.
It was submitted last term by four of our Democratic colleagues.
This is the same proposal.
So, I was told that the major reasons, or the major reason that the CACR did not move forward previously was that the state of New Hampshire, the state of New Hampshire's elected representatives are all two year terms.
Now Now, believe it or not, I know that and I knew that that New Hampshire's elected officials are two-year officials.
I sponsored the two House bills on civics that passed, so I'm aware of that.
So regarding recalls, the thinking which I understand was that if we turn people over every two years, we really don't need to have a process in place to recall them.
And I understand that.
That's all true.
But there are many locally elected board positions that are not two-year positions, as I'm sure you know, three-year positions.
That's quite a lot different.
And those positions are the ones that really prompted interest in reviving the CACR.
For example, if two individuals were elected to three-year terms on some local board, five-member board, and both individuals proved to be, you name it, radical extremists, corrupt, or otherwise unfit to serve, that district or that municipality would have no recourse but to endure these individuals for one, two, three years, they'd be trapped.
And such situations have occurred, and they probably likely will occur again.
And if or when they do, these municipalities, these towns, these districts would have no recourse but to just endure heaven knows what and I think many of us some of us think that this legislature owes it to communities to provide a mechanism that would allow districts relief when these situations occur that's why you know I think there's a need for some consideration for action here via CAECR 33, which I know is a heavy lift.
Again, I sponsored the civics bill.
So anyway, I went to serve on the school board.
And interesting, I was asked to serve on the school board.
I was a former teacher, so the teachers came to me and asked if I wanted to run, and I said, well, maybe.
And then some fiscal conservatives came to me asked if I wanted to run because I was a former teacher so the teachers came to me and asked if I wanted to run and I said well Maybe and then some fiscal conservatives came to me and asked if I wanted to run because I was both a teacher and a fiscal conservative believe it or not So I decided to run and oddly I think that these two camps didn't know that I'd been recruited by the other camp and I won I became a school board member and as a school board member.
I saw things that I'm sure many of you are familiar with.
I saw both extremes.
I saw people including some board members in our greater district who just wanted to cut everything and the opposite extreme were people who wanted to spend far more than the district or districts could ever afford.
And that's okay, but beyond those extremes in terms of philosophy, sometimes you have extremists, and there are some out there now who are on boards, who simply want to disrupt and cause trouble.
They don't have a philosophical interest in serving their community per se.
They have an interest in just messing things up.
They have been out there and they're out there now.
So, the CACR does not propose any specific recall mechanism.
It would simply empower the legislature, us, to consider future proposals in this area.
It's enabling legislation for our legislature.
So why would we not want to enable ourselves?
A possible answer might lie in a remark made to me by somebody who looked at the proposal and said What makes talking to me?
What makes you think a bunch of politicians would ever consider a proposal where they could get recalled?
Which annoyed me and I said I don't consider us to be politicians really in the normal pejorative sense of the word, you know, I consider us to be something higher than that, truly.
Citizen legislators in the New Hampshire tradition.
So, we make a hundred bucks a year, as you all well know.
So, the notion of politicians or people like us putting in or considering a mechanism for recall elections, I think is kind of a noble thing, an altruistic thing I'd be proud of.
So anyway, I think it would be inspiring for us to consider this, hopefully move it forward.
And as I look around this room, I see a lot of really sharp people, including the chair, is especially sharp.
So I'm sure that you'll hopefully give this a fair discussion fair discussion it's okay I think we've heard enough so I'm wondering if there are any questions for the representative I see one from representative Roulard Thank You representative Moffitt you said a couple of things that I wrote down.
You said there are a couple of reasons that we would want to have local officials removed.
One of them was corruption, because they were corrupt.
my question is are there local rules or ordinances that deal with any type of corruption, breaking the law, any kind of criminal activity, if they are corrupt, that would have individuals removed from their seat or if they are criminally prosec, sent to jail with a vacancy to replace them?
Great question.
Thank you, Representative Ruiar.
Yes, you asked about local situations, which is a great question, because there are, as you well know, local boards are governed by state statutes.
So I do not believe, and you may be ahead of me on this, especially if you have some legal background, locally, if there is a corrupt or a local official, a board member of some sort who is engaged in nefarious activity or alleged nefarious activity you name it The first thing locally people would go to that person and say you need to quit you know, we you know, we want you out of here and Oftentimes that I'm sure does is how things resolve themselves locally in terms of a local mechanism that you referred to that exists for a locality to get rid of a dysfunctional board member, I don't know that that exists, and you may be ahead of me on that.
Well, I really wasn't talking about locality if they have a board member that disrupts.
I'm talking about a board member that is corrupt and has perhaps a criminal prosecution coming their way and gets convicted and put in jail.
Is there a local ordinance or something that would allow that town to replace that person that is no longer on the board because of a vacancy?
Well, you know, as you know, an ordinance is a local law that's, you know, passed locally.
So a municipality could, I'm sure, vote on a warrant article or an ordinance locally to cover that.
Now, whether it would stand up in the courts, you'd be ahead of me on that.
America has a tradition of people, elected officials, being in jail.
You could Google and find a lot of people in jail who refuse to step down from their elected positions.
And in many cases, people applaud that.
So back to your point about a local ordinance taking care of that.
I don't know, and I can't off the top of my head, cite a municipality or a district in the state that has that in place.
It's very interesting, but I can't name one.
Follow up.
Let me just make it maybe a little clearer.
There may be a time where a vacancy occurs, corruption, a death, whatever it is, and the town decides that they need to fill that position.
Do they have the ability to do that now?
The question is, do towns or municipalities currently have a chance to fill a vacancy?
Now, when you say vacancy, yes, they do.
But what if there is no vacancy?
What if there is someone who won't leave?
I mean, that's the point of this is they can't fill a vacancy unless there is a vacancy.
I mean that's the point of this is they can't they can't fill a vacancy unless there is a vacancy and there's no vacancy if the if the bad apple doesn't vacate.
Follow up of that.
There is a vacancy, held due respect, if the person is in jail and they're not able to perform their duties based upon corruption, malfeasance, something that they've done, going back to your original statement, corruption, criminal process.
So you're saying that if there is a vacancy because they're unable to fulfill their duty, there is a process to fulfill that position.
There are processes to fill vacancies currently.
People can can be, for example, if there's a one-year school board, less than one year on a school board term, the school board can appoint someone to fill that vacancy if there is a vacancy.
But if someone's in jail, as you probably know, Representative, individuals are considered innocent until proven guilty.
So if somebody is in jail for whatever reason and for a short time you know there's a whole spectrum of reasons they could be in jail for how long they're in jail so just because they're in jail doesn't mean that there's automatically a vacancy and there shouldn't be what if someone's you know they deserve due process so just because someone's in jail doesn't mean there's ipso facto a vacancy.
I have another question.
One more.
Okay.
You said something about there can be individuals on school committees that have extremes.
One wants to cut money, one wants to spend money.
And my question is, isn't that the reason we elect them?
Yes, I hear your point, and I'm not sure I express that in the best way.
When I was on the board, I saw extremes in terms of philosophical, in terms of wanting to cut all spending or spend too much, those inherently are not, you know, wrong.
But there are extremes on both sides whereby someone beyond philosophy simply wants to, as I said earlier, mess things up.
They're not interested in ideologically or philosophically trying to do a certain policy for education one way or the other.
So what I'm talking about when I say extremes, beyond the extremes I saw, the extremes in terms of individuals who just want to wreak havoc.
And they know they'll never be reelected, but they're in there not for one year or two years.
They're in there for three years.
And this has happened, and I'm sure it will happen again.
And as I've already said, when these individuals end up on a board, then that right now, as I understand it, that's why this CACR was presumably submitted last term, and so why it's being submitted this term, is to give, enable this legislature to create a mechanism, whatever that may be, to give municipalities a hope of removing an individual who is just ruining their processes in their town or the municipality.
Thank you.
Further questions?
I have one.
So I'm reading on page two of the CACR that the wording of the question to be put before the qualified voters shall be and it goes from line seven to line 33.
Is that correct that someone answering the question as a qualified voter would be reading however many that is.
Sure and if if you look at it what you're looking at now the the only change I mean this is existing statute or not existing statute but it's, this is how Article 5 would be amended or changed.
And the relevant language here is on lines 12 and 13, and it simply says that, you know, we provide for and provide a recall procedure to permit citizens to remove an elected official before the end of the term of office.
So that, it's basically one line, 12, 13.
That's the very simple addition to current statute that would enable the legislature to consider, which you cannot do now without this, creating a mechanism to empower municipalities to get rid of an individual needs to be getting rid of.
Thank you.
My follow-up question is, these individuals that were elected, presumably, but are intent on wreaking havoc, or wreaking havoc, as you said, They were duly voted and maybe it is it possible though that the that the townspeople that voted for those people had the intention of wreaking havoc and and they're doing exactly what they were voted in to do and you're coming in and you're proposing that we come along with a way to change the vote.
Yeah, thank you for your question.
I think I understand the question.
And certainly, we've all been around, certainly there are cases where somebody with some, whatever their views are, people select, vote for people, hoping in some cases that they will stir things up.
And you're right, we're talking about overturning an election.
That's the definition of a recall.
So this would go to the people, to the citizens.
If a majority or a supermajority, whatever, if anything comes from this, whatever mechanism is ultimately put in place via majority or supermajority if if a if a majority of the citizens of the community desperately want their town to work or their board to work and it's not going to work if they have one or more people that are on the board for example if you take a five-, say two members are elected, and then say there's a third member who's already on the board who just goes off the reservation.
And suddenly, and this has happened, you get three out of five people on a board creating policy, whatever board that may be, that is just not in the interest of the town.
So that town now is stuck for a year or two, depending on terms, with a dysfunctional, horrible board that is ruining the town.
Very serious.
I mean, that has happened, and it will happen again.
And without a mechanism to allow a town to recall, if they so desire, but via majority, supermajority, whatever, an individual, then we, you, are condemning a town to chaos for a year or two.
It's really a very serious thing.
Does it happen often?
No.
Does it happen?
Yes.
Do we have a responsibility to give these municipalities an option for some sort of relief?
Obviously, I think so because I revived this CACR that is a mentioned before for for Democratic representatives submitted before thank you question representative is media thank you mr.
chair and thank you Moffitt so do you do you you by chance know the exact bill or wording that the Democrats, when we brought a similar bill, what it was?
It's this.
I just essentially lifted what was submitted before and resubmitted it this time.
So what you're looking at, I believe, because I pulled it from what was previously submitted, this is what came in last term.
Oh, last term, okay.
I was just curious about that.
Can you remind us what was the outcome of that vote?
Yes.
The outcome of this previous, when this came in before, was ITL'd, obviously.
And one of the sponsors came to me and said, everybody said, two years, two years.
Don't you know we have elections every two years and we don't need this?
And as I said at the beginning of my remarks, I know that New Hampshire positions are two-year positions and this really is not particularly aimed at elected to your positions it's what happened after left this room I was not here last term due to ill health voters Voters get sick of me apparently for one term.
But anyway, I was not here so- You were one of those wreaking havoc.
Was that what it was?
I hope I would never wreak havoc.
I'm sure you would.
Perhaps, I know that it was ITL, but I'm not sure if you- I don't know what the floor vote was.
That's what I was asking.
I believe it was, I'm not sure if you I don't know what the floor vote was that's what I was asking I believe it was I'm not sure I was not I was here two terms though not last term and I'm not sure if there's anyone here last term who might recollect the floor vote on it it was on consent I'm not sure the chair is here you you were the chair at that point you know know what happened to the...
Okay, doesn't matter.
We'll find out.
Further questions?
Anyone?
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you all.
I think that closes out our day.
Thank you for showing up.
Thank you for your diligence today.
That's already on the list for us today.
Does anyone have any further information for us?
I plan on scheduling the other bills for next Wednesday.
We're good with that, right?
Do we and and I would for those members that are listening online, I would very much prefer to hear beforehand whether people are intending to show up or listen online for purposes of either getting substitutes or knowing whether we can exact bills or anything that comes along We would like to know so either contact myself the vice chair or our ranking member Yep, that'd be great.
Thank you very much everyone I honestly don't know what happened.
I just...
I don't know.
Okay.
Well, I understand this committee has...
Yeah.
Not this year, I guess.
Well, it really...
This is not usually a controversial committee.
Thank you.
Merci.